hong kong pro-democracy newspaper apple
daily has said
it may be forced to stop publication
within days after the government froze
its assets
more than 500 police officers raided the
newsroom
and arrested five executives last
thursday saying its articles had
breached a sweeping chinese national
security law
the company's ceo jimmy lai was already
charged and imprisoned
under the same law in april the
government froze the company's assets
leaving it
unable to pay staff the paper now says
its
friday issue is likely to be its last
for more i'm joined now by phoebe kong
dw correspondent in hong kong
greetings phoebe a pro-democracy
newspaper apple daily will stop
publication in five days
why exactly
well last week uh two out of five uh
apple data executives were arrested and
are charged for conspiring collusion
with foreign forces
it is the very first time the national
security law targeting
media coverage because they are accused
of
publishing thousands of online and
printed articles
lastly urging for international
sanctions against china and hong kong
and apart from the individuals is also
the first time the authorities
prosecuting the entities for
violating national security law three
companies linked to
apple daily including is a printing and
internet company were also prosecuted
for the same charge
so leading to a freezing of his exit
amounting to
18 million hong kong dollars so uh this
action and the prosecution and the
freezing effects
basically make it uh make it impossible
for apple daily to conduct any kind of
banking operation
and it's really hard for it to sustain
any kind of like uh publishing or
like a daily routine and um salary
payment
of stuff like even so um this is the
the major reasons of like um like
indirectly
like shutting down apple daily in like
by financial means
so give our viewers some perspective
here phoebe how big a setback to the pro
democracy movement
is it for apple daily to close
apple daily was founded shortly before
hong kong's return to china to china
in the late 90s and just yesterday is
marked
the uh the 26th anniversary of the
uh very critical newspaper um so uh it
has long been an icon
and one of the most critical voices
against like
the chinese communist party and also the
authorities
and hong kong and china as well um so
like uh
is facing like a setback a very
like possible chance of shutting down of
this very critical newspaper
so it will be a very like symbolic
watershed
moment for the press industry in hong
kong
dw correspondent phoebe kong many thanks
phoebe
you